on passe maintenant à notre carrière du
samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
ammann corps re bonsoir
vous êtes né le 29 novembre
1990 à ce club dans la banlieue ouest de
londres en angleterre
vos parents sont tous les deux
travailleurs sociaux d'origine indienne
ils sont arrivés en angleterre il y à 26
ans c'est un petit frère de 6 ans 2 mois
que vous vous grandissez hasseloff dans
un environnement familial tout à fait
normal les années s'écoulent doucement
ponctuée par des voyages en inde pour
aller voir votre famille restés là bas à
part quelques remarques
désobligeantes sur la couleur de votre
peau vous êtes plutôt épanouie
et c'est à 11 ans que votre vie bascule
alors que les premiers signes de puberté
apparaissent la poitrine les premières
règles des poils commence à pousser sur
votre visage
diagnostic vous est atteinte du syndrome
des ovaires polykystiques ou syndrome de
steyn l'emmental ça déséquilibre
hormonal qui touche 5 à 10% des femmes à
des degrés divers
malheureusement la barbe n'est pas le
seul symptôme de cette maladie il ya de
la prise de poids du diabète de la clé
et des menstruations
déréglé plus une pilosité sur le torse
sur les bras et sur les jambes et là
c'est le début d'un long chemin de croix
à l'école votre pilosité
devient la source de harcèlement
quotidien
une torture permanente
c'était horrible on n'arrêtait pas de me
harceler à l'école tous les jours
et à cause de harcèlement je détestais
mon corps avait essayé les crèmes
dépilatoires et plus des plus agressives
utilisées même la pince à épiler mais
rien n'y fait rien n'y fait vos poils
poussent vous sombrer dans la dépression
vous vous réfugiez dans votre chambre
pour mettre fin à tout ça et là vous
pensé au suicide
ma chambre c'était moi refuge le havre
de paix dans lequel j'allais pour
échapper au monde j'avais personne à qui
parler du problème je n'avais pas
vraiment de moyen de me décharger tout
ça
miracle vous vous dites
toute l'énergie que tu mets à vouloir
mourir tu peux la mettre
pour faire quelque chose de mieux
l'extraordinaire
arrivé les gens ne se rendent pas compte
de quelle force il on a besoin pour dire
un jour j'ai envie de me tuer et je me
suis dit tu as vécu avec tant de
négativité dans ta vie pourquoi est-ce
que tu ne seras pas de transformer cette
énergie négative en énergie positive
alors j'ai repensé à toute ma vie et je
me suis dit les gens ils te disent de
haïr ton corps pourquoi est-ce que tu ne
serais pas de l'aimer et c'est ce que
j'ai fait l'extraordinaire bagram
ordinaire une preuve de courage
incroyables
elle a retourné la situation d'une façon
incroyable à vous avez 16 ans c'est
l'année de votre baptême chic et chez
les sikhs on doit garder son corps
intacts comme dieu vous la donner ce
jour là vous prenez une décision qui va
bouleverser votre vie vous décidez de ne
plus jamais vous raser
au début tout cet aspect religieux de ma
vie
c'était ce qui a fait que j'ai peut-être
conservé mes poils mais maintenant j'ai
gardé mes poils pour montrer la société
que on peut être différent on peut être
différent des autres mais quand même
s'aimer soi même aimer son corps et je
pense que maintenant je garde plus ma
barbe pour montrer à l'ensemble la
société qu' il ya plusieurs beauté il
n'y a pas qu'une forme de beauté on est
tous beaux on a tous des aspects
différents et il faut laisser les brefs
en parler avec tout le monde alors en
voyant vos poils poussent et vous
redécouvrez votre corps vous arrêtez de
vous faire du mal vous tomber amoureuse
de vous même de votre corps et vous
dites j'aime ma barbe et jeu-là chérirai
toujours
j'aime ma barbe à ce jeu je l'appelle
madame à barbe elle est magnifique
en fait je peux pas m'imaginer la vie
autrement vous avez vu les photos de moi
avant sans la barbe avec la barre vous
voyez bien que sans la barbe ça n'a pas
l'air naturel moins bien sans la barbe
c'est sûr
merci
est désormais calé grand soin de votre
barbe fait des shampoings vous faites
des après-shampooing vous mettez des
huiles et puis surtout on a un produit
qui s'appelle kalamazoo qui est un
nettoyant spéciale de la marque love
alors après le lycée vous travaillez
comme elle d'un domicile auprès
d'enfants de 2 à 3 ans ensuite vous
découvrez le charity business vous
devenez militante anti harcèlement vous
multipliez les interviews et vous fait
même des shooting glamour dans les
magazines anglais on voit les photos
vous êtes devenu de beurre 10 dames
alors conclusion vous avez une phrase
que j'adore aimez vous
vous êtes le seul mois que vous ayez
tout et dit savourer
pompiers
bon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous qui mettez un peu
de bleu